[Music]
everyone was talking about this one toy
that premiered at the New York Toy Fair
and it's a children's toy called wiki
bear yeah and it made a lot of news it
made a splash
it's a tots absolutely real it's a
talking teddy bear that actually is
connected online it connects to
Wikipedia and then it answers kids
questions kids can ask the bear a
question it accesses wikipedia through
bluetooth and then it gives the answer
that's amazing well we tried one out on
our show a couple nights ago it didn't
go perfectly you're gonna be honest with
you but I've been told wiki bear has had
a major software upgrade that should fix
any issues that we were experiencing so
I thought shouldn't we give it one more
try on the show right now he's got a
little switch in the back let me turn
that on hello I'm wiki bear what's your
name my name is Conan O'Brien
Conan Christopher O'Brien emmy-winning
television personality born in Brooklyn
Massachusetts
yes that's all that's amazing oh yeah I
can answer any question you have by wiki
bear here's a question what was the
second animated film produced by Pixar
chicking now
[Applause]
got it that movie was a bug's life
released in 1998 I actually think that's
correct that's that's really great
speaking of bugs Chicago gangster bugs
Moran was the intended target of Al
Capone st. Valentine's Day Massacre
where seven of bugs mob associates were
brutally gunned down in a blood-soaked
garage a Twinkie bear
look Eber I don't think anybody wants to
hear about the people getting gunned
down in a garage
the hidden men were disguised as
policemen which just goes to show you
kids never trust a cop no you should
trust cops that's terrible that was one
incident Capone died of syphilis that's
it just let's try another question
Wiki Barrett when was the Eiffel Tower
built the Eiffel Tower was erected just
in time for the 1889 World's Fair and is
now one of the most iconic sites in
Paris that is absolutely right yeah
merci beaucoup
and speaking of Paris sites are you
familiar with the Candiru parasite a
tiny bit horrifying blood sucking fish
that lives in the Amazon it can travel
along the human urine stream and
straight into your penis why would you
say yeah after that about a parasite
going into your penis imagine a pain so
intense you'd rather tear off your own
genitals and endure it one second no no
no I'm glad I don't have genitals all
right no you you don't you don't okay
here's a question even you can't ruin
wiki bear at what age are most people
considered happiest according to a
survey conducted in England by age 37
most people have completed all their
basic life goals so the happiest age is
37 yeah I had no idea that's a really
fun fun yeah here's another fun fact 37
is also the number of victims claim by
the Zodiac killer
a serial murderer who told the police he
was collecting human slaves for the
afterlife do you know do not tell kids
about the Zodiac killer alright even
though he left plenty of clues he was
never brought to justice
he's probably still out there dreaming
up his next creative murder I'm wiki
bear all right no just stop it I don't
want to hear any more but he was just
thinning out the herd yeah we should
thank him no no we shouldn't thank him
that's terrible you're a terrible toy
for children all right I could hold a
gun I'd kill you right now
take a look morality is an illusion
Nietzsche was right show us don't quote
Nietzsche bear we'll take a break we
write what the universe is random in
absurd right we'll take a break when we
come back everyone too many yeah
[Applause]